How's the online personality
tests coming along?
It's coming along pretty well.
We have all the reports
written and we have the,
um,
the underlying computer
architecture finished.
And at the moment we're just
polishing it up essentially.
And we're hoping that you'll be able to
get a very detailed description of all
five of the big five traits,
right?
Extroversion.
That's a positive emotion dimension.
Um,
that's,
that will break down into enthusiasm
and assertiveness and neuroticism.
Now it breaks down into withdrawal.
Like if you're in a state of withdrawal,
then you're frozen with fear and,
and don't want to do anything.
You're afraid to go out.
You're,
you're afraid to engage in any
complex task because you might fail.
You'll dealt yourself intensely.
That's withdrawal in neuroticism.
And then volatility is that kind of
impulsive touchiness that people often
develop when they're in a bad mood.
You know,
where if you reach your
finger off to touch them,
they'll flinch and maybe slap you.
And they're over sensitive
to small slights and they
don't have much of a sense
of humor.
Um,
and agreeableness that subdivides into
compassion and politeness and the liberal
types are more compassionate and the,
uh,
conservative types are more polite and
politeness seems to be something like
acting in accordance with the social
norms governing interpersonal interaction.
Whereas compassion seems to be the
proclivity to side with the weakest party,
something like that.
And I think it's the primary maternal
dimension because the perhaps alone with
higher levels of negative emotion because,
um,
it's obviously the case that when
you're dealing with children,
especially infants,
that you should take the side
of the weaker party pretty
much no matter what the
logical argument and sprite because an
infant who's crying is always right,
especially if it's under a year old.
There's no logic to it.
It's,
it's an a priori fact that
a crying infant is correct.
And so we don't know how that translates
into the political sphere because the
most direct translation would be,
um,
a complaining person is always right.
And you know,
I see that manifesting itself.
I would say great.
Clearly in the politically correct
domain is that you always side with the
person who's manifesting negative emotion.
And you always assume that there is
an external reason that needs to be
rectified in order to,
um,
to deal with that.
And you know,
it isn't obvious to me that agreeableness
as an ethic is something that is
transformable into the political
or the adult landscape.
But,
um,
well,
you know,
we don't know these sorts of things and
we can't even talk about them because
people automatically assume that that's
sexist or misogynistic or even though
you know,
there are agreeable manner as well as a
group of women because men are quite um,
maternal for,
for,
for the kind of large apes
and mammals that we are.
But we need to take these sorts of things
seriously because it isn't obvious to
me that an ethic of agreeableness
can govern a complex polity.
It looks to me more like conscientiousness
is something that needs to govern
arm's length transactions and that sort
of thing rather than treating everyone
like Ken that you just can't do
so you don't have the energy.
Um,
anyways,
the test will also associate
conscientious or assess conscientiousness.
That's orderliness,
which is seems to be
associated with disgust,
sensitivity and is a good predictor of
conservative belief and industriousness,
which is something like the,
well it's what it says exactly.
It's the proclivity to engage in
effortful work towards a defined goal in a
reliable manner and it's the second
best predictor of longterm life success
after Iq.
And then the final thing it'll upset,
assessed is openness to experience,
which is more or less half creativity.
It half interest in ideas.
And so if,
if you take the test,
you'll get a boat,
it's about a 10 page report and it gets
quite detailed and it tells you where
you fit on a percentile basis and what
your strengths and weaknesses are going
to be.
As a consequence,
we're going to produce a couple's version
so that two of you can take it and
then you'll get a report that tells you
how you're similar and different and
where you're likely to have disagreements
and agreements where it's going to be
difficult to negotiate a consensus.
That'd be where your Wyatt widely
different from one another on a trait.
Like it's hard for an extrovert and an
introvert to come to an agreement about
how much socializing they're going
to do because the extrovert says,
well,
let's socialize all the
time in the introvert says,
well,
you know,
once a year would be plenty for me.
And those aren't opinions right there.
They're built in preferences that
are far beneath the realm of opinion.
And if you're high in openness and
your partner as low in openness,
like you're going to be interested in
the theater and arts and literature and
philosophy and,
and talking about ideas and,
and going to museums and not
sort of thing and your partner,
it's in some sense it will
be like they are colorblind,
they just won't find that sort of
thing engaging and interesting at all.
And you might be able to shift someone
a little bit to a higher degree of
openness,
but it's,
it's not an easy thing to do.
And so we think in the literature seems
to indicate that you should be fairly
well matched on most of your
traits with your partner,
uh,
with the possible
exception of neuroticism,
because it isn't obvious that two people
who are highly neurotic can get along.
Uh,
neuroticism is a pretty good
predictor of marital unhappiness,
just like it's a good predictor of
every other form of unhappiness.
So.